John Monagle:
I'm here in front of McCosh Hall, and today
it's Dean's Date, the semester's final deadline
John Monagle:
for the submission of all written work. It
may look quiet now, but by this afternoon
John Monagle:
you'll be seeing students running everywhere,
trying to make that 5 p.m. deadline.
John Monagle:
You'll also see a huge party.
Band leader:
Now, here we go. One, two. One, two, three, four.
[Princeton University Band music]
Shreya Murthy:
So I think it's really good that
Princeton does have something like this.
It's a great stress relief.
Shreya Murthy:
I just turned in my assignments and now I get to
come here and get free food and really just relax.
Shreya Murthy:
I really like that they do this. It's
really considerate.
Zach Zimmerman:
We're on the scene live at Dean's Date 2010
Princeton University. Who am I talking to?
Bethy Atkins:
Bethy.
Zach Zimmerman:
Talk to me about how many pages you are pulling.
Bethy Atkins:
I actually only had one essay due today, which
is surprising because I'm an English major.
Bethy Atkins:
I finished it around 2 p.m. and got to relax
for a while.
Zach Zimmerman:
Did you stay up all night?
Bethy Atkins:
No.
Zach Zimmerman:
What?!
Bethy Atkins:
I know, I know. It was the first time. It's crazy.
Zach Zimmerman:
What? No! We're done with you.
Please tell me you had some pages due.
Michael Gunter:
Art historian -- I had 18 pages due.
Zach Zimmerman:
I love it. I love it.
Michael Gunter:
I don't love it. But I turned it in already.
Zach Zimmerman:
Have you ever had to run with a paper?
Neil Mathur:
Sophomore year, second semester, I had to
run with two papers actually. That was a very
Neil Mathur:
close call.
Shreya Murthy:
Yeah, actually for moral support, I ran with my friend.
Jonathan Schwartz:
I have never run with a paper. I mean, only
just to get it off my hands four hours before
Jonathan Schwartz:
the deadline, but I've never been cutting it that close
to run with a paper. I think it's great that
Jonathan Schwartz:
Princeton puts up a little party. We get some
popcorn. There's ice cream.
Jonathan Schwartz:
This is a really great way
for the administration to give back to the
students and say, "We care about you, and
Jonathan Schwartz:
we are there for you."
[singing "Old Nassau"]
[music]